المستوى الثالوث الاستراتيجي
النووي والمستوى التكتيكي وهذا
انا اصنفه الدفع باتجاه سياسة
حافة الهاوية. بوتين الانتصار هو
امر حتمي ولا رجعة عنه كييف ترد.
لن نغفر لموسكو وعشرون الف جندي
يؤمنون موسكو والبريطانيون
للاوكران. لقد ارهقتم اقتصادنا
ومجنون كوريا يودع عام الفين
وثلاثة وعشرين بطريقة خاصة بينما
كوريا الجنوبية واليابان
تستنجدان بمجلس الامن. الصين
ترسل رسالة لواشنطن نحن هنا فاين
انتم? والصواريخ التركية تتسكع
في الاجواء الدولية والجزائر
تفتح صفحة جديدة مع فرنسا والامم
المتحدة تجامل فلسطين على غير
العادة ترحب. وايران تناور بجميع
انواع الاسلحة لاجل هدفها
الجديد.
استراحة محارب. عام جديد بدأ
والهدف لم يتغير بالنسبة للروس
والرفض الاوكراني يراوح مكانه.
وها هو وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
شويجو يهنئ القوات المسلحة
الروسية بالعام الجديد ليؤكد ان
انتصار روسيا في عمليتها
العسكرية الخاصة لحماية اقليم
دومباس من بطش نظام كييف امر
حتمي حسب قوله. ليرد وزير الدفاع
وبنفس اللغة ونقصد هنا اللغة
الروسية مطالبا الروس بمغادرة
بلاده مضيفا ان السلطات الروسية
ستعلن تعبئة جديدة بداية العام
الجديد بسبب خسائرها الكبيرة في
اوكرانيا. هناك عاد دوي
الانفجارات العنيفة وصداها يتردد
في كييف مجددا. ليعلن عمدة كييب
عن حالة التأهب القصوى بعين
السكان للبقاء ملاجئ والدفاع
الروسية تقول انها وجهت ضربات
مكثفة على مواقع اوكرانية ودمرت
ثلاثة وسبعين موقعا للقوات
الاوكرانية في ست وثمانين منطقة.
ليعلن رئيس هيئة الاركان
الاوكرانية ان الجيش الروسي
استهدف مدنا اوكرانية عدة
باطلاقه عشرين صاروخا وخصوصا من
قاذفات قنابل. لافتا الى ان
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني اسقط
اثنتي عشرة من ليخرج الرئيس
الاوكراني الزلينسكي غاضبا ويؤكد
ان بلاده لن تغفر لروسيا قصفها
بعد تلك الضربات الكثيفة. لكن
الرد الاوكراني جاء كذلك باعلان
هيئة الاركان الاوكرانية عن مقتل
مائتي جندي روسي في مقاطعة
خرزون. بينما اعلنت كييف استعادة
السيطرة على بلدة في مقاطعة
لوجانسك لتعلن سلطات جمهورية
قوات كييف استهدفت اراضي
الجمهورية بحوالي مائة قذيفة
خلال ثلاث ساعات فقط لترد روسيا
بالنفي حول ما صرحت به هيئة
الاركان الاوكرانية. ومن حرب
المقذوفات الى حرب الاحتفالات.
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
يظهر ليقول ان الحق الاخلاقي
والتاريخي الى جانبنا بينما اتهم
بوتين الامريكيين والاوروبيين
باستغلال اوكرانيا وشعبها بوقاحة
لاضعاف روسيا وتقسيمها وقال كان
الغرب يكذب بشأن السلام وكان
يستعد للعدوان. واليوم لا يخجل
من الاعتراف بذلك. ليتم الاعلان
عن مشاركة عشرين الف عسكري في
تأمين الدفاع الجوي والصاروخي
لموسكو خلال عطلة اعياد رأس
السنة وذلك بحسب مصدر في وزارة
الدفاع الروسية. في الجانب
زيلينسكي يهنئ بمناسبة رأس السنة
ويقول انه ناقش مع القيادة
العسكرية مسألة تعزيز الدفاعات
الجوية مؤكدا ان قوات بلاده
تحافظ على مواقعها في بخموت
وتتقدم في مناطق اخرى فزادت
التهنئات وانتثرت التبريكات في
ارجاء اوروبا وكل يغني على
ليلاه. ليأتي خبر سار لاوكرانيا
عبر الوكالة الدولية للطاقة
اعلنت استعداد ثلاث محطات نووية
لانتاج الكهرباء في اوكرانيا
مجددا بعد الهجمات الصاروخية
لروسيا. وبمناسبة رأس السنة ايضا
قالت روسيا واوكرانيا انهما
افرجتا عن اكثر من مائتي جندي في
احدث تبادل للاسرى بين الجانبين.
ومن اوكرانيا الى بريطانيا. حيث
انتقد البريطانيون رئيس الوزراء
ريشيسوناك بشدة على كلمته في عيد
السنة التي اكد لهم فيها دعمه
لاوكرانيا وذكروه بانهم احق بهذا
الدعم الذي ارهق اقتصادهم وانعكس
على معيشتهم. كم يحتفل بطريقته
الخاصة. الدول تحتفل بالسنة
الجديدة. وكيم يحتفل ايضا لكن
على طريقته الخاصة حيث اختتم
عامه باطلاق ثلاثة صواريخ
باليستية باتجاه بحر اليابان.
تقدم احتجاجا لدى سفارة كوريا
الشمالية في حلقة جديدة من
التوتر المتصاعد في شبه الجزيرة
الكورية لتعلن اليابان سقوط احد
هذه الصواريخ الثلاثينية. بينما
قالت كوريا الجنوبية ان حادثة
اليوم انتهاك واضح لقرار مجلس
الامن الدولي ليصف رئيس هيئة
الاركان المشتركة في كوريا
الجنوبية الحادثة بالمستفزة.
ودعا كوريا الشمالية الى وقف هذه
الاعمال على الفور. قائلا
مستعدون بالكامل للتصدي لبيونج
يانج بالتعاون مع امريكا. ماذا
بكم? ما الذي اقلقكم? انه
المجنون فقط واراد ان يحتفل
معكم. تركيا تشعل الاجواء
الدولية. تركيا تقطف ورقة من
كتاب مجنون كوريا الشمالية لتبدأ
العمل بالطريقة الكورية تعلن
انقرة انها اختبرت بنجاح صاروخ
سيبار ون الذي اصاب هدفا على بعد
مائة كيلومتر وتعتبر هذه التجربة
بمثابة هدية رأس السنة الميلادية
للامة التركية بحسب وكالة
الدفاعات الصناعية في تركيا. ومن
حفلة التجارب الى احتفال الطاولة
السياسية حيث اكد وزير الخارجية
التركي مولود شاوش اوغلو ان سحب
القوات التركية من سوريا يتطلب
تقدم العملية السياسية هناك لكن
اوغلو قال ان اللقاء الاخر مع
سوريا سيكون خلال النصف الثاني
من يناير بعد ان خرج اللقاء
الاول بين دمشق وانقرة بنتائج
ايجابية بحسب التقارير التركية
والروسية. الاحداث والتطورات.
بعد ان مرت حاملة الطائرات
الصينية عبر المضيق بين مياكو
واوكينا والى هي تقترب من جزيرة
بوام اكبر مركز للجيش الامريكي
في المحيط الهادئ. دعا الرئيس
الجزائري عبدالمجيد تبون فرنسا
الى فتح صفحة جديدة في العلاقات
بين البلدين كاشفا عن زيارة
سيقوم بها الى باريس خلال العام
الحالي. الامم المتحدة تطالب
محكمة رأي العدل بشأن الانتهاكات
بحق الفلسطينيين وباغلبية
الاصوات لترحب الرئاسة بتصويت
الجمعية العامة للامم المتحدة
لصالح فلسطين. حكومة اليابان
تقدم عروضا مغرية لمواطنيها
لمغادرة طوكيو ولمدة خمس سنوات
على الاقل لمحاولة تخفيف
الاكتظاظ السكاني في العاصمة.
اجرت ايران مناورات عسكرية واسعة
النطاق لقواتها بمنطقة سواحل
مكران جنوب شرقي البلاد على طول
الساحل الجنوبي وصولا لبحر
بمشاركة وحدات من المشاة
والمغاوير الى جانب وحدات بحرية
وقطاعات جوية في التدريبات حيث
اختبرت مختلف انظمة الدفاع الجوي
والمسيرات الاستطلاعية والهجومية
محلية الصنع. فماذا تحضر ايران
للعام الفين وثلاثة وعشرين
برأيكم? سنة جديدة وبوتين
وزلنسكي يحتفلان بهدوء. واردوغان
يحتفل بصخب بينما احتفال كيم
جونغ هو